everyone so welcome back for the
afternoon session and uh today we're
very happy to hear from raghu mecca from
ucla will be telling us about learning
gaussian graphical models without
condition number bets
hi everybody uh
today i'll tell you about gaussian
graphical models which kind of continues
to
talk that the anchorman that ankur gave
to the morning he was talking about
graphical models learning graphical
models when you have latent variables
in this talk i'll take a different
dimension where we're still talking
about learning graphical models
but this will be in the space of
continuous graphical models we have all
the variables but we have very different
constraints and different challenges and
this is joint work with john kellner
freddy kohler and ankur who is here
from mit
okay
so the talk has three parts first i'll
talk about what ggm's are why are we
studying them and then the special
models and the specific algorithm that
we're going to study which is in this
box here
and then i'll say a few words about what
we can actually analyze about this
algorithm
so what are gdms or gaussian graphical
models if you're me they're just a fancy
word for multi-weighted gaussian
distribution
everyone knows what a multivariate
gaussian distribution is
and usually when we think of a gaussian
distribution we parameterize it b by the
covariance matrix right so in this talk
i'll follow statisticians notation so
the number of features the dimension
that we're working in will be p
okay so you have a p-variate
multivariate
p-variate multi-dimensional gaussian
distribution covariance matrix is sigma
and
usually we never think about the formula
of the pdf of the gaussian distribution
but i wrote it down here
because there's some
reason this sigma and versus show up
right
the twist today is that
instead of talking about gdms where we
gaussian instead of talking about
gaussian distributions parameters
covariance matrix today we'll talk about
parameterizing them by the inverse of
the covariance matrix which is called
the precision matrix so theta which is
sigma inverse and while we're studying
the precision matrix
this goes back to this very nice
property of gaussian distributions from
i think identified with damsel in 72
that the precision matrix
encodes the conditional independent
structure of the gaussian distribution
what do i mean by this
so you have the precision matrix which
is sigma inverse
then
the dependency graph of the distribution
is exactly the support of the precision
matrix
okay and dependency graph also showed up
in encore stock basically it encodes the
markup property of the distribution
in what sense you take your precision
matrix build a graph where two vertices
are adjacent if the corresponding entry
is non-zero
then
whenever the entry is zero those two
variables are independent condition on
the neighbors of one of the vertices
okay so this is the markov property that
holds for the distribution with respect
to this specific graph
okay
so for instance here
x1 and x3 would be independent condition
on the neighbors 2 and 5.
and another reason we're going to look
at the precision matrix is that we're
going to parameterize
the complexity of the distribution very
differently right so we have a p
variable gaussian distribution but we're
going to assume that the distribution is
simple in the sense that the precision
matrix or the max degree of the support
graph g
is small is d which is much less than p
this kind of the same setting as we saw
in the previous talk
okay and this is the assumption that
makes talking about precision matrices
meaningful
or interesting that you know this
condition the precession matrix is parse
is very different from what you get
traditionally by looking at the
covariance matrix
why are we looking at these ggns
well there's a very nice model for
various statistical relations between
variables especially in applied sciences
i found many uh
applied works which use gdms to model
the distributions that they're facing
and people also have used them for
various network data but i don't want to
go into these things too much today and
the bigger picture that we're looking at
in previous talk this talk and maybe a
little bit even in the next talk is
i give you some distribution right
under the assumption that the dependency
graph as we defined before is sparse
can you learn the distribution
can we learn the dependency graph from
view few samples
okay this is just like learning markov
random fields learn undirected graphical
models all of these are rephrasing to
the same question
for instance in anchor stock we talked
about learning easing models right so
you have a distribution one minus one
and you have the dependency graph
and under some conditions on the
dependency graph you want to learn the
distribution
all right there's a lot of work on that
but today we're going to talk about the
continuous world where
the problem is different but also i
think a little easier
in terms of upper bounds
okay
so
i'd like to give an example that you
should keep in mind this will be the
running example for the talk and also i
think something to play around in your
head with
so suppose uh
you have a p varied multi p
multi-pivoted gaussian distribution
which is generated as follows
i generate p independent gaussian
distribution z1 to zp these are iid
but then the actual variables that you
observe are the prefix sums
right so x i is x i minus 1 plus d i so
the first sum of the first i z is x i
okay
now what is the covariance matrix of
this distribution you know you can just
do some arithmetic to see that it has
this
seemingly simple structure but it's kind
of very dense
what is the precision matrix of this
distribution
any guesses
yeah
yeah
so if you look at the precision matrix
you exactly get this matrix right it's
very simple it's three sparse
each row column only has three non-zero
entries and the dependency graph is just
line graph right it's just packed
okay
and it kind of makes sense and it's like
a markov chain in that once i give x i
minus one you know what you see
afterward is independent of the past
in the context of learning sparse ggm's
there are two questions one is
structural learning
given samples from this distribution can
you learn the dependency graph
the other question is parametric
parameter learning
where i want the learning gaussian
distribution which is close to my
samples in some way or maybe even
estimate the precision matrix entries
exactly within some errors
okay so structural learning is just you
know you're given samples x1 through xn
n is the number of samples
and i'd like to output the dependency
graph of the gtm
this is what we're trying to do
and the challenge as i said often is
that
especially in the context of gaussian
graphical models that the number of
samples you have is much less than the
ambient dimension p
what can you do in this case for
gaussian distribution you know if you
have linear and
dimensional many samples you can do
whatever you want you can estimate the
coherence matrix really well
then you can invert it make a standard
gaussian you can build a basis do
whatever you want but we're in the case
where the number of samples is going to
be much less than ambient dimension
but this is still a meaningful question
to ask because of our assumption that
the precision matrix is sparse
so that kind of saves us here
so in summary the question we're
treading is the following
i'm giving you n samples from
multivariate gaussian distribution where
n is now much less than the ambient
dimension you should typically think of
it as logarithmic in p
and we'd like to find the dependency
graph of the gaussian distribution
all right
okay
and as i said you know once you know the
dependency graph you can estimate the
parameters easily because then it
becomes a d dimensional problem instead
of a p dimensional problem and you can
do standard stuff there yeah
when you write o sub d you mean it's
linear
oh no it's some function of b in front
that's fine the main thing we are
shooting for the first step is to get
logarithmic dependence in p
in fact in our bonds at least the
dependence is going to be d log p or d
square log p or something like that so
it's not bad
but i said the biggest thing is is it
logarithmic or linear in the dimension
any other
questions okay
so let's go back to our example right
just kind of instantiate a version of
this problem
earlier we had the random walk
uh distribution now suppose that
you're looking at the same random work
example but it's a random walk in some
permuted order
there's some unknown permutation pi
and what you're saying is
you know x pi of phi is x pi of five
minus and plus di so it's prefix sums
but under this permutation you don't
know the permutation all you're seeing
is the variables samples from this
distribution
how many samples do you need
to recognize the permutation to learn
the permutation from this
do the same thing again the dependency
graph is still going to be a path but
it's some jumbled up
order and you have to find out what the
order is
how many samples do you need to find the
hidden permutation
a very simple concrete question
algorithmic and
kind of even from a statistical
standpoint it's interesting how many
samples do you need and how much time do
you need to find such a permutation
all right
okay
so i mean ggns as i said has been very
well said in the statistics literature
there's a lot of papers and also some
popular software packages like lasso
climate acclaim and so on which are used
across various fields
and one of the most used ones is this
package called glasso
and what they show is that you can
indeed learn the dependency graph with
very nice sample complexity d squared
log p so that uses logarithmic
dependence on the dimension but they
need a strong assumption that the
precision matrix is incoherent okay
under some sense which i'm not keen on
defining now in the interest of time
but this is a strong assumption that is
violated by the random walk model that
we just looked at
in fact it's violated by most models
when you have long-range correlations
and similarly this is work based on
linear programming which can also learn
the dependency graph with logarithmic
and p
dependence on the dimension and the sum
m to the four where m is some kind of
condition number
which is the maximum ratio of the
entries in sigma and theta
okay
so in both of these cases the
incoherence or this ratio of entries and
sigma theta is some notion of condition
number of the distribution
once again this is violated by the
random walk example that we just saw
and so the previous works were only
known to work under well-conditioned
precision matrix
scenarios
and this is not just that you know the
analysis doesn't work the algorithms
actually do fail empirically when you
take simple twists of the random walk
model
so this uh it's not just a matter of
getting better analysis
so before going on let's first ask
ourselves is it even possible
information theoretically or what is
possible information theoretically
and this is net precise in a very nice
version of mishra wufre and loka in 2018
who gave him almost
a precise characterization of what you
can learn and how many samples do you
need for gaussian graphical models
so to make this uh to define this i need
to introduce a parameter which i call
tapa
and there's a formula here
but what it essentially measures is the
signal that is present in any two by two
sub matrix of the precision matrix okay
or in other words if let's say i'm
trying to identify an edge i j how
strong is that edge with respect to the
corresponding variances right you can
imagine if this entry theta aj is very
small with respect to the variances then
you know it's very hard to identify
so this is a parameter and the nicest
thing here is it only depends on
pairwise sub matrices or two by two sub
matrices how strong is a single edge and
not on the global structure of the
entire distribution
so it just measures signaling two by two
sub matrices and not the whole matrix
and what they show is that under this
definition information theoretically
d lock pure kappa squared sample suffice
to identify the dependency graph
okay
and
for instance if you go back to the
random walk model
this parameter kappa is exactly half
just to clarify when you say
identifiable with the sample size do you
mean that you can bound the probability
of an error for the whole precision
matrix uh
you can identify the dependency graph so
it will be something like okay with d
log p or kappa square times log one over
delta samples maybe
uh with probability one minus delta you
will identify you'll output a graph
which is exactly the true graph okay
there's a failure probability in term
which depends on log one or delta and
just condition on the sample
so you can see that for random rock
models kappa is half so you should be
able to identify the unknown permutation
with only logarithmically many samples
and this is also
tight in some sense in that there's a
lower bound due to bang bang written
ramachandran show that you do need log p
or kappa square samples to identify the
graph
there is a catch in this result
in that the run time of the algorithm is
p to the o of t
its polynomial for fixed degree d but it
grows as the degree grows
the runtime grows
and the reason the speed to the update
kind of shows up is you're essentially
enumerating or all possible
neighborhoods like a single vertex and
then you kind of rule out which one is
the true one which one isn't the true
one
okay so the main question that we
address in this work is when can you
beat this enumeration in all possible
neighborhoods
can you get a runtime
which is a fixed polynomial in p even
for
large d
and you get runtime even p to the little
of b
so we want to use log in in p minus
samples runtime should be a fixed
polynomial
and the main thing we do in this work is
the answer is yes for a large class of
models the information theoretic result
applies for all gaussian graphical
models and our result applies for a
large class of models which are which
have been studied in various contexts
within statistical physics in for
gaussian graphical models and other
things okay
so and also i'd like to say that the
algorithm is very simple and it also
recovers the guarantees of lasso incline
so kind of strictly more general than
the previous
algorithms that were used
okay
so that's the question that we're going
to study and the motivation and now let
me tell you about what the algorithm is
and what are the special models for
which we are able to prove that it works
the first model is attractive ggms which
is again a little bit like the
ferromagnetic assumption that we saw in
course talk
and here
we say gtm is attractive if all
covariances
are
non-negative okay meaning all two
variables all variables are positively
correlated
in the when you invert the matrix and
look at the precision matrix it
translates to saying that all
off-diagonal entries in your precision
matrix are negative
and this shows up in gaussian few fields
and as many applications for gaussian
processors in particular the random walk
example that we saw is definitely an
attractive model the off diagonal
entries were just minus one or zero
this was a random work model
and it's an attractive model
and even though it's an attractive model
it's kind of simple
it it is the condition as long as the
graph is long paths so the existing
results do not apply even for this
attractive models
and the lower bond also applies here
for attracting more lower bound of log b
applies here
back to the previous slide sure um what
happens do you get these
do you get these attractive ggms if you
consider generalization of the random
walk model so instead of having just
a markup chain you have other types of
dependencies between the variables
uh you mean like you know maybe prefix
sums as long as the coefficients in your
equations are
positive i think you get it back
tomorrow
i mean yeah in terms of precision matrix
it's a little bit difficult to look at
but in covariance matrix it's easier as
long as any two variables their
correlation is positive it's attractive
good question
okay
and what we do is given algorithm which
we call greedy prune and we'll see it
learns attractive models
with
d log pure kappa square sample
complexity which is kind of what we are
shooting for and the runtime is only
quadratic
and the more general class of models
that we study is uh are called walk
summable ggms
and this is a bit of a technical
definition but it does arise in many
other contexts so what when is a jgm
walk summable
well you start with your precision
matrix you have your precision matrix
here you have all the diagonalities and
all diagonal entries
you take every octagonal entry and make
it negative
okay
i get a new matrix
the original precision matrix because it
is coming from a gaussian distribution
it is positive semi-definite is the
inverse of the covariance matrix which
is pst so it is psd
whenever this operation preserves psdns
we call the matrix walk summa group
okay so i replace every object length
with negative absolute value
the resulting matrix is still positive
semi-definite and the original matrix is
waximov okay and this was introduced in
the context of statistical physics but
there are many classes of ggm's which
are studied in the literature which fall
under this umbrella of auxiliary models
for instance you can take attractive
models
all their off diagonal entries were
negative to begin with so the operation
does nothing okay
you can take something called pair as
normalizable models or non-frustrated
models and if you're coming from
theory-related pressure if you think of
symmetric diagonal dominant matrices
they're all voximable because you know
they guarantee that their psd is very
much only depends on the absolute value
of the entries
okay
so these models were said in the context
of learning jgms and the best algorithm
was again something like p to the o of t
and this was known even before the work
of
mr wilfred local
in 2012
and what we do is what we show here is
that the greedy prone algorithm learns
these models also
with log ethnic and p dependence
and the dependence on degree d and kappa
kind of is worse than for attractive
models but they're still polynomial and
runtime is again quadratic
all right
and as a carrier we can actually improve
it further to get you to d lock your
capital four by combination of the
greedy algorithm that we're going to see
and the
l1 minimization algorithm
all right
so let me now tell you what the
algorithm is this is very similar in
spirit to the one that um could describe
where we're going to use a greedy
approach to build the graph
so just to recall the setting is we have
samples from the ggmx and we're trying
to build a dependency graph of x
so the algorithm has two phases where
let's say you know forget the entire
graph i'm just trying to figure out what
are the neighbors of a single vertex
and i want to identify what are the
neighbors of vertex 1 i'll do this in
parallel for all the n vertices
and in first phase i'll grow a candidate
neighborhood i'll pick a bunch of
vertices which in which i think will
contain all the true neighbors and in
the second phase i'll throw out some of
the vertices
so how do i grow a neighborhood
again we're trying to focus on vertex
one
and the way we grow the neighborhood is
very simple a simple greedy rule
and the greedy rule is as follows as
long as the set of vertices speaks so
far is small
i pick a new vertex which gives me the
most bang per buck
in terms of reducing the variance
of the vertex that i'm trying to build
the neighborhood of
in other words
i look at the variance of x1 here
conditioned on all the vertices that i
already added plus the new vertex j
whichever j minimizes estimate i'm going
to add that to my set of vertices
the idea is that you know conditioning
on the neighbors should reduce your
variance the most
conditional variance
okay
and that's the algorithm i mean i'm
using true variance as a number here but
you can use estimations for that in your
algorithm and doesn't change too much
and interestingly if you're familiar
with compressing literature
this algorithm is actually equivalent to
something called orthogonal matching
pressure
just as an aside
and it just happens to be the same as
omp which is very nice
okay
now once i have the neighborhood what do
i do with it well you might overshoot
the set of neighbors and have some
spurious neighbors so we just throw some
of the neighbors out some of the
vertices out
and what do i do for throwing things out
if they are useless i mean okay so
if dropping a vertex does not hurt the
conditional variance too much i just
drop it
okay so it's kind of throwing off all
the dead weight
and once again we're using estimates on
the conditional variance
and just keeping those which are
really helpful in maintaining the
variance
so that's the entire algorithm
and just to give you know
uh
an example of what happens when you use
this in practice so here's a case of
ggm's where i have a single long path
just like the random work example but
then i also have some clicks some four
by four clicks thrown in
it's a very simple instance the
precision matrix is path plus clicks
kind of looks like this you have zeros
almost everywhere
you have a small
patch of non-zeros along the diagonal
and the max degree is three it is an
ill-conditioned gtm when you run the
algorithms
this is what happens
so the greedy algorithm kind of really
recovers most of the graph exactly the
other algorithms have some non-zeros on
the of diagonals
okay
and you can plot this further and check
how many samples
is each does each algorithm require to
identify the graph with reasonable
certainty okay
and
by changing the intensity along the
cliques you can defeat all the other
algorithms but the greedy prone
algorithm kind of almost always grows
the dependence on the dimension is
logarithmic
for instance here you can see that
client package the dependence on the
dimension times the number of samples
needed is growing nearly linearly
whereas greedy is flat
and
glass is also flat but then if you
change the intensity the other one fails
whereas greedy still works
all right
so let me get to
the interesting part which is how do we
actually prove these theorems in the
last five minutes i'll give you a hint
of what goes into them
so just to recall here are the two main
things that i talked about
greedy prone learns attractive models
with d locker kappa squared samples in
runtime
and for maximal models it's worth
slightly worse than d squared log p or
capital six
and i say it also requires glass or
incline guarantees when you have the
incurrence or condition number
assumptions as before
okay so about the analysis
the analysis for attractive models is
much easier and kind of follows from
this concept of super modularity that
anchor mentioned so if you it can be i
can define a function on subsets of
vertices
which is
the conditional variance of x1 given
excess given all the vertices in all the
values in s what happens to the
conditional variance
and this function turns out to be super
modular it was known before and once i
know it's super modular
the definition is here
i can use greedy algorithm to run it
right just as before if i have super
modular function i can maximize it and
you have to maybe spend a little bit of
time to
make sure that you can do it with
samples
but that's not too
difficult to do
okay we don't have exact access to the
function f of s we have an approximate
oracle for it but we can manage to do it
and
the issue though is that when we go to a
slightly more general case of walks and
google models this function is no longer
super modular
or various there are various weakenings
of super modularity under which we do
know greedy algorithms do work
but none of those conditions hold
so why does greedy still work for vox
mobile models even if you don't have
super modularity here
and here we use a connection to
symmetric diagonal dominant matrices and
the punch line is that for walks and
mobile models under some suitable
normalization
knowing a single neighbor
gives you a lot of mileage in figuring
out the entire neighborhood
okay
let me illustrate this and i'll skip
this for now okay
so
one special case of voxel matrix are
symmetric diagonally dominant matrices
and these are matrices where the
diagonal entry is larger than some of
the off diagonal entries this is kind of
essentially guarantees that the matrix
is waxable
now for all of these matrices
for any vertex i
there exists a single neighbor
that once you condition on all the
conditional variances drop down
dramatically
they now only depend on kappa squared
so there exists a neighbor
that is comparable to conditioning on
the entire neighborhood
and the whole problem in this setup of
gaussian capital models is that
individual variances can be much higher
than the conditional variances
whereas this bond is saying that there
is at least one neighbor where once you
condition on it all the conditional
variances are kind of bounded
and if they're bounded small which don't
depend on p we can detect it with few
samples
and the proof of this uses uh
the triangle inequality of effective
resistance metrics on graphs and
properties and conditional variance
so it kind of connects to this
literature and effective resistance and
graph
okay so in the last one minute let me
tell you one special case of this bound
so for intuition assume that you have a
precision matrix where the off diagonal
where the diagonal entries are one i'm
just normalizing it so that this is true
then the condition kappa translates to
saying that every non-zero of diagonal
entry is at least kappa and magnitude
they're not too negligible
and the lemma says that under this
condition the conditional variances are
bonded by one over capital
okay so they cannot be p or p squared or
anything like that
so that's the main thing so for instance
if you go to the random walk model
the variance of the vertices on the
right or in the middle are linear in the
dimension p variance of x p over 2 is p
over 2 plus 1 okay
but the conditional variances wherever
you're on the line is still just 1.
right so this is a dramatic drop between
variance versus conditional variance in
this limit saying this holds for all
std precision matrices
and this is not true for general sparse
position matrices
it's only true for this special case of
matrices
okay there's a proof here in quotes
which i'll leave it at that
okay
so to summarize we started this question
learning ggns
and the main question as i said is
assume that the parabolas correlation
cup is constant
can you learn it in runtime p to the
lead flow of d and sample complexity
that is you know as long as sub linear
and p i'll be happy
and we saw a simple greedy algorithm
which solves interesting special cases
and a lot of open problems here can we
solve more general custom models i don't
even know how to test if a model is
correct i give you samples from a
distribution i give you a model that
gives you a graph and a precision matrix
tell me are the same
what happens if you have hidden
variables
and
i actually think that the problem is
computationally hard in general but we
really don't have any evidence for this
you know my conjecture is that there's
no p to the little of the algorithms to
require the structure of gtms
with these many samples
uh so i'm just curious so a very similar
algorithm arises in learning um directed
graphs and so i'm wondering if you have
any sense for
uh this the if the walk summability
criterion is how close to necessary it
might be please read the algorithms
uh so we were able to transfer examples
where where really would fail
so i don't know if it's exactly
necessary for the graph to be walk
summable but there are simple cases
where the greed algorithm would fail
so yeah that's very good question that
you know we still at least i don't have
a very good sense of what the hard
problems should be here
and that's a good thing to have like you
know we need a set of
candidate models which we think are
computationally hard
all right
all right so continuing the afternoon
session we have freddy kohler speaking
um who i guess you know was at mit at
the time but is now at stanford so
please take it away